the political philosopher Hannah Arendt
one of the greatest thinkers about
authoritarianism once observed that the
political left always goes to motive
always argues that its opponents are not
just wrong but evil remember that it's
important we keep being told that the
Cavanaugh confirmation process has
further intensified America's political
polarization for which blame lies on
both sides as I said last week I can't
stand partisanship and hope to help
build a cross-party movement behind the
ideas of positive populism but right now
at this moment one party stands in the
way of that with its extremism hate and
rage no it is not both sides it is one
side you've never heard a Republican
leader talk about Democrats like this he
has been a racist he's been sexist he's
been Islamophobic he has been anti LGBTQ
I mean there's a long list it it I don't
think it's useful to say oh we figured
it out this is what he is he has a view
of America that is incredibly
constricted and he talks to that America
he talks to them all the time and it's
by no means a majority as we know but it
is a very hardcore who are responding to
him and supporting him that America
honestly you've never seen a Republican
senator say anything like this please
get up in the face of some Congress
people and what exactly did a Republican
representative ever do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
these daily scenes of mayhem and
violence how many of those hate build
faces are conservatives do you think no
it is not both sides it is one side it
is one side that started this cycle of
hate and no it was not Mitch McConnell
blocking Merrick garland here's the
senator who first stated that no Supreme
Court justice should be appointed in a
presidential election year President
Bush should consider following the
practice of a majority of his
predecessors and not and not name a
nominee until after the November
election is completed he is the senator
who ended the 60-vote filibuster rule
that promoted bipartisanship on judicial
appointments to change the rules
regarding presidential nominees will
apply equally to both parties when
Republicans are in power these changes
will apply to them just as well that mr.
president is simple fairness simple
fairness and here's the senator who
throughout centuries of bipartisan
advise and consent tradition and vowed
to block a Supreme Court nominee within
hours of his announcement before a
single second of testimony before a
single case had been reviewed I will
oppose him with everything I've got and
now who's escalating the armed race of
hate last time I looked
this man was a Democratic presidential
candidate not a Republican I believe
that our party the Democratic Party must
be a party that fights fire with fire
when they go low I say we hit harder
sure enough the left and now saying that
justice Cavanaugh must be impeached or
the Supreme Court pact will have more on
that later in the show because he's too
political but I don't remember
conservatives calling for the
impeachment of Justice Ruth Bader
Ginsberg over this quote I can't imagine
what this place would be I can't imagine
what the country
would be with Donald Trump as our
president said the justice for the
country it could be four years for the
court it could be I don't even want to
contemplate that now it's time for us to
move to New Zealand and it's not that
supposed or Thorat Aryan that great
Underminer of democratic norms Donald
Trump calling for packing of the court
it's they're Democrats yes we're in
polarized times but no it is not both
sides conservative academics however
much they disagree with liberals simply
don't talk like this left-wing professor
at Georgetown University quote look at
this chorus of entitled white men
justifying a serial rapists irrigated
entitlement all of them deserve
miserable deaths while feminists laugh
as they take their last gasps a bonus we
castrate their corpses and feed them to
swine yes by the way that's not even
remarkable anymore remember Kathy
Griffin
remember Snoop Dog and now a new low as
the loonie left drags the Democratic
Party inexorably into the gutter senator
Susan Collins who over 21 years in the
Senate has sponsored 28 bills on sexual
violence who has been an outspoken
champion for women's rights who even
actually voted on Brett Kavanaugh spoke
powerfully about her hope that the
confirmation process would lead to more
justice for sexual assault victims this
decent sincere and thoughtful woman an
absolute credit to our politics was
described by the women's March as a rape
apologist the women's March is not a
fringe organization it's endorsed by
countless Democratic members of Congress
they own that when President Trump
allowed the populist movement to be
tainted by their neo-nazis of
Charlottesville I spoke out against it
on this network on this show so where
are you Kamala Harris cory booker
kirsten gillibrand
and all the other self-righteous
sanctimonious charlatans and hypocrites
who constantly lecture the rest of us
about bigotry and xenophobia will you
speak out against this hate if you don't
condemn it
you're part of it of course they won't
condemn it because hate is the less
currency hate is their energy hate is
their path to power just as Hannah
Arendt said xenophobia means suspicion
and hatred of people who are different
it is the very definition of the modern
Democratic Party their brand is hate and
if they win it will get worse November
is coming they chanted on the steps of
the Supreme Court yes it is so let's use
it to show these divisive destructive
Democrats that extremism hate and rage
will not win in America let me know what
you think of that at Steve Hilton X and
that next rev fnc what do we think of
that I think president Trump has this
unique gift where he pushes people to a
point where they unmask themselves and
they show who they really are and I
think we saw that with the left there is
no low low enough for the left that they
were perfectly willing to destroy an
innocent man and the name of politics or
political retribution for Merrick
garland or in the name of abortion or
whatever else it is and there was no low
enough and we know that they weaponized
these baseless allegations we know that
Senate Democrats went out and tried to
find accusers like Ronan Farrow said and
about his New Yorker piece which mind
you even after interviewing something
like 70 people not a single person came
forward to corroborate Deborah Ramirez a
story yet the left ran with it and it
didn't matter to them I think President
Trump so succinctly said this the other
day when he said you don't get a match
to an arsonist and you don't get power
to a left-wing angry mob and I think
Americans are sitting back right now
after witnessing this process and
realizing how dangerous the left really
is well and here's the important part
we as conservatives always try to appeal
to the better angels of Democrats oh we
probably have a lot to agree on we just
have a right to do that I thought we're
done right now we're done with that
these people might not once want what's
best for this country they want power
they want this president impeach and put
in prison I'm sick and tired of saying
that Democrats want what's best for
America they don't they don't believe in
the America of free speech of free
markets of dialog and agree to disagree
they want power and they want to destroy
anyone that disagrees with them that is
not a liberal value that is a leftist
value there's a dis there's a
distinction there's and we have that we
as the decent minded people have to keep
the moral high ground and not give them
an inch on it well and I think the moral
high ground is in fact fighting back but
let's remember the party itself has been
what's been pushed so far to the left
abandoning their there the average
Democrat the average classical liberal
and so this is what I would I would
submit that in fact you're correct there
is no real division there's not two
sides doing this but I contend that the
country itself is not divided that you
had 200 people fight you know out in
front of the Supreme Court that is not a
mass movement and as we're looking at
this shocked so are women who might be
Democrats who maybe are now identifying
as independence looking at that thinking
well this is not a real alternative to
what's going on and besides things are
going well who are these people and
they're represented and and their main
leadership there is no one in leadership
in the Democratic Party saying
forcefully this is unacceptable because
they've lost control of that dynamic I
would also suggest that the polls that
we see we know the enthusiasm gaps are
isn't for Republicans what would be it
would be a mistake to suggest that the
Democrats are responding positively to
what this is and so if I tell my radio
audience and I would tell everyone
watching this no have faith in your
neighbor you are not the only one who
thinks this and don't think that your
neighbor is the enemy or not having the
same reaction I think they are I think
that's great summary thank you all